hi everybody welcome to another exciting
edition of The Gadget Lab I am Roberto
Baldwin I'm Christina Bonnington and
today Cristina brought in her brand-new
iphone 5 we just got it bought it
ourselves it's not a review unit or
anything set it up restored from iTunes
backup and now we're ready to test it
out first off that obviously the iPhone
5 is taller than my much shorter iphone
4s 276 more pixels on the display and
display is also just a little bit
brighter I think and has a little bit
more color saturation than on the iphone
for us and of course it's noticeably
thinner and lighter mine feels fat my
knees are go to fat camp now definitely
needs to go on a diet after you're
holding that thing yeah and the both of
the cameras are a lot improved
especially the front-facing camera those
pictures are actually usable now whereas
before you didn't really want it mostly
for face kind that camera another new
feature of the iphone 5 is the
redesigned dock connector on the bottom
which is eight pins instead of 30 pins
and we have the dock connector right
here as you can see it's about the same
size as my pinky nail which is pretty
small it's a yeah small it can go in
either way it's reversible unlike the
last one which you know if you're
fumbling around in the dark trying to
plug that thing in your people like
broke some of the pins off or you stick
it in the wrong way well it's like the
USB cable when you plug in you is you
always put in the USB cable upside down
when you plug it into your computer it
was the same thing with the ipod dock
connector now it's never upside down
right unless it's sideways and you
probably have been drinking too much of
that point yeah that's not a good thing
yeah and then it runs the new iOS 6
which came out on Wednesday and that
includes the kind of iffy Maps
application that Apple redesigned from
the ground up instead of using google
maps which it's used for the past five
iterations of iOS I have a theory about
maps by the way what's your theory I
came up with it last night if you've
ever watch a TV show friend
there's an alternate universe where
everything so it looks like our
University everything's slightly
different that's the information or
using for the Maps app that's why
they're just random airports in
locations and Hoover Dam has a road that
dips into the river right which is
pretty awesome if you're you're going to
jump you can jump out the other side
yeah lots of crazy cities ending up in
rivers and oceans and giving you wrong
directions it's kind of a problem when
we rely on our maps on our smartphones
so much but with iOS 6 series gotten a
lot better you can ask your questions
about sports and movies and I actually
found that really interesting and I also
the greater Yelp integration with
opentable I'm gonna be using that all
the time making reservations and
restaurants I you know like stands and
trucks own observations sounds too fancy
so now why did you buy the iphone 5 i
can tell you why i didn't but why did
you buy it so i'm actually upgrading
from an iphone 4 so it was time uh on 18
teen my upgrade plan i decided to stick
with AT&T give him a shot because so
many people are moving to verizon i
thought well what if tons of people are
moving to verizon and then their network
gets bogged down then maybe 18 tease is
pretty good and then also coverage here
in san francisco with a teensie has
gotten a lot better lately so i figured
i'd give him a shot another shot yeah so
basically it was time for me to upgrade
i skipped down on the iphone 4s so it
was time i have the 4s perfectly good
phone don't need to spend any more money
yeah that's it that's really why I'm not
upgrading I'm sure there'll be an iphone
5s that'll have a camera that shoots
lasers and has an LOL cat generator on
or so we'll have a Christine will have a
review of the iphone 5 and a review of
iOS 6 that's actually already on the
gadget lab so check it out and we'll
talk to you next week bye